with his strategic Moves In Secret of
Whispers Otto Hightower is definitely
reminding some House of the Dragon fans
of some of the shrewdest players on Game
of Thrones throughout the first four
episodes of House of the Dragon which
serves as both a spin-off of and a
prequel to The HBO Juggernaut Game of
Thrones plenty of characters are vying
for the Iron Throne including Otto
Hightower as hand of the king to viserys
the first as well as two other kings
before him Otto knows what it's like to
be in close proximity to ultimate power
much like Tywin Lannister from the
original Game of Thrones Otto is a quiet
yet skilled schemer frequently holding
his tongue until the right moment where
he can play his cards accordingly by
episode 4 this tactic has succeeded
nicely for him as his daughter Alison
Hightower is now married to viserys and
has had two children one of which is a
boy
[Applause]
second of his name in the fourth episode
of House Of The Dragon King of the
narrow sea Otto doesn't do a whole lot
but he does make one crucial move just
before it draws to a close after
princess rhaenyra and prince Damon
Targaryen give in to their desire for
one another in a brothel and King's
Landing a confidant referred to as the
White Worm tells Otto that the uncle and
niece were spotted together
Otto quickly takes this information to
viserys the king dismisses this
information as nothing more than a
transparent ploy to get Alison's son
aegon onto the throne instead of
rhaenyra that said viserys later makes
it clear to rhaenyra that he does
possibly believe Otto
the truth does not matter rhaenyra only
perception
even with viserys's potential belief
that Otto's information was true Otto is
essentially fired as hand of the king
but he still has plenty of cards up his
sleeve his daughter Allison is still the
Beloved second Queen to viserys and at
the rate she's going she might end up
giving birth to another Heir before long
plus aegon is certainly a viable
candidate for King also Otto May well
have a stronger influence the further he
gets from the throne working from the
Shadows to achieve his goals the show
has frequently alluded to the fact that
he has collaborators lurking in Old Town
maybe we'll finally get to see what
alliances he's formed there throughout
the series thus far Otto has shown
himself to be shrewd to perhaps a fault
in the aftermath of viserys's wife's
death he wastes little to no time in
sending Allison to comfort the king
resulting in a betrothal between the
teenage girl and much older physically
ailing viserys he also even suggests to
viserys that rhaenyra for whom viserys
is desperately trying to find a suitable
husband marry her younger half-brother
aegon who is at that point two years old
viserys might have fallen for Alison's
nightly visits but even he's disgusted
by Otto's proposition to marry rhaenyra
and aegon all in all Otto's tactics are
likely to remind fans of Peter
Littlefinger Baelish as well as Tywin
Lannister he's also definitely grossing
audiences out what he does next remains
to be seen But now that he's no longer
hand he may have to return to Old Town
to rally the troops he apparently has
there so we may get to revisit that
location before long
[Music]